>> Greg: SHED A TEAR FOR THE
DEARLY DEPORTED.
SOME FAR LEFT DEMS ARE PUSHING
TO AND TARGETED DEPORTATIONS OF
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
INCLUDING SUSPECTED GANG
MEMBERS.
WHICH I GUESS WOULD MAKE THOSE
FELONS ANCHOR CRIMINALS.
NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ --
THAT'S FUNNY?
THIS COUNTRY IS AT A "RACIAL
RECKONING."
I MISPRONOUNCED HER NAME, THAT'S
FUNNY.
SHE JOINS 34 DEMOCRATS AND
DEMANDING AN IMMIGRATION
OVERHAUL INCLUDING PULLING BACK
ON TARGETING GANG MEMBERS FOR
DEPORTATION.
SHE'S RIGHT, THESE UNDOCUMENTED
FELONS ARE COMING HERE TO COMMIT
FELONIES THAT AMERICANS WON'T DO
THEMSELVES.
AOC WRITES "THE DEFINITION OF AN
AGGRAVATED FELONY IS A RELIC OF
THE RACIST WAR ON DRUGS."
IT INVITES RACIAL PROFILING BY
RESUMING AN EMIGRANT AS A
PRIORITY IF THEY'VE BEEN
CONVICTED OF A KNOWN FUNDS IN
WHICH THEY WERE ACTIVE
PARTICIPATION IN THE GANG OR
SOMEONE OLDER THAN 16 WHO MAY --
I HAVE TO TAKE A BREATH.
SHE IS CRITICIZING WHAT SAYS
THAT WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE THE
GANG MEMBERS.
SO WHERE'S THE RACIST PART?
WAS THE GUY WHO WROTE THE MEMO
WEARING BLACK FACE AT THE TIME?
I MUST'VE MISSED IT.
KEEP IN MIND, THESE GANG MEMBERS
MOSTLY PREY ON OTHER
CENTRAL AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS WITH
CRIMES INCLUDING MURDER AND
CHILD.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT MIXING
RECYCLABLES OR MISS GENDER AND A
CASHIER.
THESE ARE BAD PEOPLE DOING BAD
THINGS.
SO WHEN AOC'S WORLD, WE CAN PUT
THESE FELONS IN PRISON AND WE
ALSO CAN DEPORT THEM.
SO WHAT SHOULD WE DO WITH THEM?
GIVE THEM THEIR OWN SHOWS ON
CNN?
I HEAR THEY ARE HIRING.
IT ALWAYS FEELS LIKE THE FAR
LEFT -- THEY HATE AMERICAN
CITIZENS MORE THAN THEY HATE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CRIMINALS.
IF YOU CAN'T PUT THEM IN JAIL,
WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THAT?
>> THIS IS THE ONLY CATEGORY
THAT YOU CAN CURRENTLY DEPORT.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THEY REVERSED
EVERY POLICY.
THIS IS THE LAST THING THAT WE
ALL AGREE ON AND GETTING ROBBED
OF VIOLENT GANG MEMBERS WHO ARE
HERE ILLEGALLY.
I'VE OFTEN SAID THAT THE TWO
PARTIES APPEARED TO BE A TACKING
TOWARDS DIFFERENT GOALS
CURRENTLY COME OUT WHICH FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY -- I THINK THIS IS THE
EXAMPLE OF IT.
THIS WOULD BE A BLANKET AMNESTY
AND MEANWHILE THE SOUTHERN
BORDERS POURING IN AND YOU DON'T
THINK THERE'S PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO DO BAD THINGS.
BUT THAT IS POLYAMOROUS.
>> Greg: I WISH I KNEW WHAT
THAT MEANT.
I WAS HEAR PEOPLE SAY THAT, AND
I THINK IT MEANS NAIVE?
>> VERY GOOD, GREG.
>> Greg: THAT'S A VERY
INTERESTING THING ABOUT HOW THE
PARTIES ARE GOING THIS WAY -- IT
ALMOST FEELS LIKE YOU ARE
ENTERING THE STAGE OF TWO
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
THERE IS ONE THAT'S LIKE OKAY,
FINE.
THESE STATES WILL DEAL WITH
THEIR EMIGRATION IN A DIFFERENT
WAY THAN THE STATES.
IT'S BECAUSE THE STATES THAT ARE
FURTHER AWAY FROM WHERE THAT
PROBLEM IS THAT HAVE ALL THE
GREAT IDEAS.
I COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH AOC
ON THIS ONE COME I THINK THIS IS
A GREAT IDEA.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO A LITTLE
INFOMERCIAL FOR JUST $0.06 A
DAY.
YOU CAN ADOPT A GANG MEMBER,
BRING THEM TO YOUR HOME, TAKE
ONE CHILD HEAR OR SEE ME NO
MORE.
THESE THREE TEARDROPS AWAY FROM
BEING A NEW SOLDIER.
WE CAN FLY MEN TO YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD, HE COULD STAY WITH
YOU FOR JUST $0.06 A DAY AND
YOUR YOUNGEST DAUGHTER.
BUT MY POINT IS, IF YOU BROUGHT
THEM TO THEIR DOORSTEP OR THEIR
TOWN, THIS WOULD NOT BE THE
THING.
THEY BE LIKE, WE NEED NATIONAL
GUARD, WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING.
>> Greg: IT'S INTERESTING.
>> TALKING ABOUT WHAT YOU NEED
TO DO, THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES.
I THINK WE ARE HEADED TOWARDS A
ROTATION, A WORD I HAD TO LOOK
UP TODAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
MY VIEWS ON IMMIGRATION HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN, ANY NONVIOLENT
PERSON WHO WANTS TO COME
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ECONOMY TO BE
ABLE TO DO SO, BECAUSE I DON'T
BELIEVE IN A WELFARE STATE.
MATT, AND THAT'S ALWAYS WHERE
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT HAVE
DISAGREED WITH ME.
AND NOW APPARENTLY THEY'RE ALSO
GOING TO DISAGREE WITH ME ON THE
VIOLENT PART.
IT'S REALLY TRULY SHOCKING.
I'M OKAY WITH DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST VIOLENT PEOPLE.
I DON'T LIKE PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
VIOLENT CRIMES.
I ALSO THOUGHT IT WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE YEARS AGO
WHEN I WAS DOING STAND-UP, THERE
WAS A GUY WHO GOT CAUGHT WITH
COCAINE AND HE GOT DEPORTED.
HE WAS A WHITE GUY WHO GOT
DEPORTED BACK TO LONDON.
SO WHAT SHE CALLED OUT AN
INJUSTICE TOO?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW, YOU
LOST YOUR CONNECTION.
THAT'S NOT TRUE, SHE DOES NOT DO
DRUGS, DOES NOT DO DRUGS AT ALL.
AT LEAST RIGHT NOW WHILE WE ARE
ON SUCH.
AFTERWARDS, IT'S ANOTHER STORY,
ALL BREAKS LOSE, DO IT OFF
DR. DREW'S HEAD.
IT WOULD WORK BETTER OFF THAT.
>> FIRST THING I THOUGHT OF WHEN
I SAW YOU.
>> THERE'S SO MANY THINGS THAT
HAVE HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHERE
THEY ARE GOING.
THE HOMELESS THING IN
LOS ANGELES, I WAS ASKING
SOMEONE, WHAT IF THEY SHOW UP ON
MY LAWN?
WHAT IF THEY GO INTO MY SON'S
BEDROOM?
>> EXACTLY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY
LOGIC IS, THERE SEEMS TO BE NO
LOGIC OR NO "WHERE WE ARE GOING"
WITH THIS.
THAT IS THE PART I FIND MOST
DISTRESSING, BECAUSE IT'S NEVER
ENOUGH.
IT'S JUST BEEF CONSTANTLY.
WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO DO?
>> I'M NOT AN APT APOLOGIST, BUT
I THINK IT'S MY PREVIOUS POINT,
THEY ARE NOT AFFECTED, SO
THEY'RE TALKING FROM THOUSANDS
OF MILES AWAY.
IF THEY WERE IN THE MIX, THEY
WOULD NOT BE SAYING THAT.
SHE WOULD BE THE FIRST ONE
CALLING "THERE IS GANG MEMBERS
OUTSIDE MY HOUSE."
THERE IS AMERICANS CARE WITH
SHOTGUNS AND BLADES, I HAVE TO O
GO.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, IF YOU
MAKE THAT PHONE CALL, YOU ARE
RACIST.
NOW EVERYTHING IN WHICH YOU ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IN LIFE BECOMES
RACIST, YOU CAN NO LONGER
PROTECT YOURSELF BECAUSE THAT
ITSELF IS RACIST.
>> IT'S JUST CONFUSING.
HOW DARE YOU DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST AGAIN?
>> I'LL JUST BE THAT RACIST GUY
WITH IN MY FRONT YARD.
I'LL TAKE THE HEAT.
>> Greg: THE TRADE-OFF --
WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON.
UP NEXT, A GUY WHO WAS RELIEVED
OF COMMAND FOR HIS ANTI-MARXIST
STANCE